hey guys after reading some of the
comments on my channel I realized
there's a lot of stereotyping and
assumptions that's made by a lot of guys
when it comes to women so in this video
I'm gonna share seven things that every
guy shouldn't know about woman let's get
to it mistakes mistakes make you strong
that's just very quick if your first
time here on my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to DLN model lifestyle if you
haven't subscribed yet then please
consider subscribing and then also
clicking that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's start with the first thing you
need to know about
[Music]
not all women are the same are you the
same as all together guys out there no
in the same way all women are unique of
course there will be some similarities
but then once you break through the
walls once you have a real meaningful
conversation you will start to see who
she really is
[Music]
all women appreciate the little things
now that all of them have in common it's
not about the amount of money that you
spent on her it's about the little
things like buying flowers now just to
be totally honest here of course there
are gold diggers out there a lot so if
you see that she cares too much about
money then run the other direction
that time of the month yes it is real
and it can be dangerous and here's the
thing it's more important when the
period strikes it's more important for
her that you try to understand her
emotionally compared to you
rationally so remember if she's on an
appearance she got some problems he
tells you about the problem don't try to
solve the problem just rationally
because it's not gonna help you gotta
show her that you understand emotionally
all she needs is a hug and then she'll
be fine but now I also want to warn you
here about something because some women
use the period card to their advantage
to manipulate guys because they know
that you won't really know how to
respond in the situation so be careful
she's not perfect some guys they fall
into a trance when they really like a
woman she's beautiful and she's just
perfect
she looks perfect she walks perfectly
she talks perfectly and everything she
says
is perfect the halo effect look all men
and all women we're all far from being
perfect and remember she's just a human
being she poops just like you on the
toilet if you go into the relationship
there will be disagreements so you gotta
expect it so that when it does happen
you're ready for it and you handle it
with love and understanding
women don't want to be your mother
well first of all nobody can beat your
mom because your mom your mom's always
gonna be your mom but most women most
women have this inherent need to take
care and support the men in their lives
and it's awesome there's something
special and gentle unique that a woman
brings into a relationship but she
doesn't wanna be your mom and just clean
up after you and serve you she wants you
to serve her as well you know I never
understand these guys when a woman works
and a guy works and I come back at home
the men expect their wife to do
everything for them take care of the
kids clean the house do the washing do
the dishes and then she needs to jump
whenever he wants coffee so ridiculous
look if both are working and if you're
at home get off your lazy ass and go
make the coffee or self and go make some
for her as well and then help her with
the chores as well
[Music]
most of the time women just want you to
listen and understand them we guys we
just tend to think rationally right we
think rationally about creating
solutions to problems but most of the
time when a woman comes to talk to you
they don't always want you to work out a
solution for the problem they just want
you to really understand their feelings
she's not always saying these things
just so you should fix it for her she
just wants someone to listen to her to
understand her so do it just listen to
her give her a hug and you'll see she'll
be brand new
heart overlooks yes of course your
appearance is very important especially
when it comes to grooming and style and
you really taking care of yourself
because it shows self-respect but your
heart your personality your character is
more important it's the same the other
way around for you as a guy for me when
you look at a woman the appearance is of
course important but the heart is more
important you know those type of girls
who look beautiful but their heart is
dark oh these girls with a terrible
arrogant selfish personality guys don't
like that but compare that to a woman
who also it takes good care of herself
her appearance but with a gentle honest
beautiful sincere gentle heart every guy
loves it that is a diamond and so it's
the same way the other way around it's
the same way women look at men as well
now just a bonus tadhana be rock-hard
softened up your heart and tell her how
you really feel and think about things
because that's the only way that she can
really connect with you and get to know
you alright guys let me know what you
think about all of this in the comment
section down below and I'll see you in
the next video Cheers